and minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Melbourne
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists indeed we are
welcome to episode 139 today we're gonna
talk about ownership versus access and
if you're watching the video version of
this you probably see we have a special
guest in the studio today and we'll get
to that in a second but if we were
regular podcast this is where the
advertisements would go we would just
start talking about underwear and
mattresses and other other vaping
apparently is they get away at the
podcast you know the food delivery meal
services we don't do that but since we
are talking about access today I did
want to talk about something so my
birthday was on Friday and well the
hometown that were from were from a city
called Dayton Ohio and born and raised
there and on the west side of Dayton is
one of the largest food deserts in the
country and so we often when we think
about Acts access to things we'll think
about access well today we'll talk about
access to parks or maybe vehicles or
housing we often don't think about our
access to food it's one of the things we
take for granted because I can go down
to the grocery store in my neighborhood
and I can buy the apples and the carrots
and the lettuce and the meat and
everything else I need to to survive but
in Dayton Ohio there's one of the
largest food deserts in the country
there it's the second hungriest city in
the United States and the reason being
is there just isn't access to healthy
food and so what Ryan and I are deciding
to do and you all can help out with my
birthday as well we're trying to help a
co-op called the Jim City Market build
the first grocery store on West Dayton
in about a decade the the Kroger that
was there went out of business in 2008
and it's gonna take a lot of effort a
lot of money and a lot of planning and
we're trying to raise a hundred thousand
dollars to help build this this grocery
store in West Dayton and so if you all
will talk more about that toward the end
of the podcast but if you're interested
in helping out with that I just turned
thirty seven and
so if you want to donate $37 for my
birthday I could use it a whole lot more
than a tie clip or pair of suspenders
are you returning that tie clip like I
if you would and then once you return it
take that money go to the minimalists
comm slash Dayton okay and you can get
more information on that grocery store
we're trying to build you can help out
also if you can afford more than that
$90 gets a family a lifetime membership
to the coop so the minimalists comm
slash dayton if you're interested now if
you're watching the video version of the
podcast you probably see this tall man
to my left his name is Ryan Delk he's
from a company called Omni and well
we're talking about access today I
thought we don't do interviews but
occasionally bring people on to help us
answer some questions I thought you were
the right guide to to answer some
questions here because you're the CEO o
of Omni which I've had I've been trying
to explain Omni to a few people and I've
had I've had a bit of a struggle okay
explaining it and I was hoping maybe you
could explain it to me although the way
you you tweeted about this recently you
said one way to think about Omni is that
we empower you to own the things you
want to own and access everything else
and it sounds to me like Omni is a
company that wants people to have access
to things that they may not want to own
what is what is Omni Abell yeah so
that's exactly how I think about it so
we think about Omni as empowering people
to access the things that they want to
own be that essentials be that hobbies
whatever it is to be able to own those
things and then bill to access
everything else and so the idea is you
know we have we live in a world where
sometimes things are needed and because
of infrastructure and life decisions and
whatever people have just accumulated a
ton of this stuff right and so we think
of it about these items that you use
once a month or once a year or once
every five years and items that might
take up a ton of space in your home and
items that might also be valuable to
other people and so the whole goal of
Omni is to build a platform that allows
people to access these things when they
need it and not have to keep those items
around their house and so you get two
benefits one is instead of
things you can just pay for things by
the day or the month or the week when
you need them and on the flip side you
can also free up room in your house and
make money on things by sharing them
with your neighbors your community
sharing with your friends for free and
so we think about it hopefully as sort
of building this future where everyone
can own way more but be able to own way
less but be able to do way more with
things I love it what so what like where
you were you all out right now with on
me yeah like what cities where can
people use this service currently yes so
we started about three years ago we're
currently in the Bay Area we cover most
of the Bay Area and then we're actually
coming to Portland partnering with the
city of Portland to bring Omni there
later this summer and so the story of
omni's a little interesting we started
knowing that in order to build this sort
of network allowing people to share
things we needed to get really high
quality goods and so we started as a
management platform where you could add
deposit items that you own so you could
put your drill your bike and you could
get it back whenever you need it so you
could free up space in your home but if
you still wanted to go bike riding on
the weekends you could have your road
bike delivered and so it wasn't storage
it was all itemized we took really nice
photos of it we would deliver it back to
you but that was really the foundation
so we spent two years building that to
build up sort of this network of items
that we could then unlock the value up
for the world you don't have any items
you can't lend right now I can't go into
my house and zap a ladder and say oh I'm
gonna write this out to someone else and
be pretty fast now Nicodemus was talking
about this last night we we were driving
home from the airport and I picked you
up yeah and you're like there's this
ladder I use maybe once every other
month or some someone yeah I've got a
ladder to get to my roof and it's nice
to go up every once in a while for
sunset and like you know check out the
Hollywood Sun yeah have a glass of wine
or something but it's like the other
thirty days during the month I don't use
it it'd be nice to make five or ten
bucks off of it and ladders are
interesting because they have a costs
not just to you an opportunity cost of
what you can make financially but it
takes up a ton of space yeah yeah it's
on my patio transporting it is you know
it's taking up room back there it's
transporting it is terrible and so you
know we think about the value that we
create not just in this sort of you know
money that you can make on items or
whatever but freeing up space in your
home and we think spaces should be for
living not for storing for storms stuff
yeah amen and the weird thing is we're
building houses that are larger than
ever and then two things happen
is we just overtime fill it with stuff
you know I remember I built when I built
my first house in Dayton Ohio and
suburbs of Dayton I was you know it was
this huge monstrosity with full basement
two-and-a-half car garage which I don't
know how you fit a half car in there
okay is that a Prius or something thank
you put three Prius is in there and and
of course you
most people are filling their garage of
us stuff so they they have a two and a
half car garage that barely fits one car
because of the ladder and all this other
stuff the and so in a weird way we start
to lose access to the things we even own
because it's just piling up there in the
basement or the closet or the Attic and
how often do we actually go and use
those things so we're paying for all
this extra space and we own these things
yes meaning we sort of hoard them but we
we don't we don't actually use the
things totally and it seems to me I've
been waiting for a business to come
along and have this model where you know
you're sort of the uber for stuff is the
way that that I'm sure it was pitched in
some venture capitalist meeting
somewhere at some point in time but
that's the way that I see it right i I
look at that and I say because growing
up I didn't have to have a basketball
court in my back yards or have access to
play basketball and you you didn't need
access you didn't have to I mean people
have swimming pools in their backyards
but I didn't have one I mean we grew up
or [ __ ] and I had access to the YMCA
swimming pool though and and now it's
like well how can we do that with
individual items whether it's Ryan's
ladder or I was on the website I saw all
kinds of things on there like it's not
in Los Angeles yet so yeah I can't use
it yeah but I'm really looking forward
to the day where I can get that
Chewbacca costume that I $10 a day or
something you're just gonna do it like
to record one episode of our podcast
with video and just being a true Bach
outfit and not say a word about none of
us mentioned but there are other things
in there and even things like books I
got so Melvin Gladwell book on there
and you know it's like a dollar a day
and you're like well that's what
libraries do but maybe this and there's
something here if I'm getting a bunch of
other items and all by the way I always
wanted to read the tipping point now all
of a sudden I can at the same time and
and the nice thing is you're taking you
you're freeing up space in one person's
life and then you are you're giving
access to that same stuff to too many
other people while I'm not using it
I was thinking recently and our friend
Rob Bell just did an episode about this
I've seen more and more of these now
these little scooters yeah burden line
do they have them up in the Bay Area
they did they got rid of them government
just yeah set it down but well they are
they're amazing but the problem is like
people don't put them back in the bike
rack like theirs so they just end up
thrown everywhere all sidewalks that's
sort of the beauty of it the yard yeah I
mean it's it's great for us if if we
don't if we don't own that yard that all
the birds are thrown in yes I haven't
seen any in the yard yet but I see a lot
especially the just the last seven days
like the last week I've seen a ton of
them but both of them bird and in lime
and people are leaving them on like
street corners so it'll be on like yeah
the corner of Sweetzer and and Beverly
or something where that blue bottle
coffee is and you see one there and you
see a lime on the opposite corner and
I'm definitely gonna try it out this
week you see there's so much fun so so
just for our listeners that this is a an
electric scooter
that is its battery battery charged you
take a couple you know steps or a couple
pushes and like you hit the button all
sudden you can go what's crazy to me
about this whole birdlime thing is that
there are kids there are high school
kids like Chargers yeah making like
hundreds of dollars a day really yeah
I'm going around collecting these things
and then plug them in there was a um
there was this homeless dude that came
out to me in Santa Monica a couple weeks
ago when I was up there surfing and he
was like hey man you know can I get a
couple bucks and I was like yeah I'm
sure like you know I gave him a little
bit of change whatever I had in my
pocket and I was like you know these
birds I was like you know you can charge
these things and like make a couple
hundred bucks a day if you you know if
you max it out and he
like like I blew his mind he's like
really and then you got a smartphone out
downloaded the charger yeah well usually
we we have voicemails that we answer
some voicemail questions before we move
into the lightning round but today we're
going to sort of merge the two segments
together it works really well last week
when I brought my two doctors in from
nourish balanced thrive and we had a
chat and and so we didn't have any
voicemails specifically about access we
had a lot of social media questions so
we're at the minimalists on all the the
socials and we have some questions here
today let's start with our our first
question it is from Emily Emily asks
ownership at its core has to be an ego
thing right when I walked out of my
garage this morning it's all my
neighbor's new g-wagon and the garage I
got my 2004 Toyota Corolla there there I
definitely like look at that I'm like
gotta be an egotistical person to have a
freakin gy I can't things I mean I think
III think if you have the money for a
something like a Mercedes Benz yea SUV
it's somewhat like a piece of art yeah
I'm kind of projecting you because I
wish I owned a g-way I mean there's
beautiful engineering there but uh the
truth be told a brand-new Toyota Corolla
is probably more reliable sure in terms
of its engineering and you know the Six
Sigma that goes into the the design and
but also the the the manufacturing the
the sort of repetition has to be good to
produce that many of one product now
Ryan I don't know if you think that
there's ego involved in this when I
think about ownership I think there's
there's certainly necessary ownership
and what we're not saying here is you
shouldn't own anything and you should
just only have access to things that's
that's a weird sort of dystopian
communism and what I like is you've
provided a market solution to this this
problem that we have of both
overabundance and also lack of access
yeah at the same time and I don't know I
think sometimes maybe ego is involved in
ownership
I think definitely is our way I hope to
see things move is where it turns into
the things that you own you have pride
in those things in a healthy way and so
you know I think about when we talk
about like helping people own the things
they want to own if you're really into
art or sneakers or whatever it is like
that's great you should pursue those
things but you shouldn't also feel like
you have to own a drill and a ladder and
you know a boogie board and a surfboard
and a drone and all these other things
you should be able to get access to
those things whenever you need them and
so I don't know I do think I do think in
its worst form it does tie to ego but I
also think there's a positive side of
that that probably taps into a similar
motion around pride of buying quality
things which I talked about a lot yeah
which I'm a big proponent I was like
research finding great things and then
you know buy those things instead of
buying the junk that is gonna be thrown
away in a year yeah I totally agree like
it is owning stuff egotistical like as a
blanket to say yes like that's not true
right um but certainly yeah the bad side
of it it certainly can be egotistical I
think for anyone out there who's like
asking all you know it my you got cystic
oh by owning this one thing I mean
you've got to ask why are you owning
that one thing is that person owning the
g-wagen because they really do find the
beauty in the art yeah and you know they
go off-roading a lot and they have all
these throw these value adds to their
life from owning a g-wagen not to
mention it is a beautiful this is a
beautiful car or are they owning it
because they're like yeah I'm the [ __ ]
yeah man look at me I own a G Wagon I'm
awesome look how rich I am right like
maybe that's what it really boils down
to is do I own this so I can say look at
me or do I own this because I truly get
value from yeah and and if you can sort
of parse that out and maybe sometimes
it's both and then that can be a problem
as well I mean you and I both drive
Toyota's and I'm sure I could go finance
a more expensive car if I wanted to but
I really don't want a car payment so I
could you know find a way to to afford
that Mercedes Benz G Wagon but why
because it wouldn't be for me in that
case that's interesting so if you at
what I heard you say and I'm not saying
that this is true but it might be and
you know I don't I don't want to say the
majority of the time but maybe if you
are taking a loan out
on something like it g-wagen uh-huh it's
it probably might it might be and
egotistical move right because if you're
financing something to when there's a
substitute you can use that is is gonna
allow you to not finance it I mean you
might ego might get a little bit
involved there because I know like my
2004 Toyota Corolla dude I look like a
long-haired hippie driver
he's a 2004 gorilla but a surfboard rack
right exactly I don't care what people
think of me and my 2004 curl sure but a
lot of people do like they do want to
they do care about other people's
thoughts and if we're buying something
or financing something just because we
are concerned how other people look at
us or we're trying to impress someone
yeah financing might be might lean
towards that ego side I don't does that
make sense yeah what I would say is I
don't care what you think about me I
care what I think about me and the same
thing is true with with the material
possessions my car is newer than yours
and it's I don't have anything against a
2004 Toyota Corolla but I prefer to have
a different car from what you have and
there's nothing wrong with it but I have
it for me it's not to impress anyone
else I don't care what anyone else
thinks all you drive a Toyota like I
live in a building where there are a lot
of BMWs and Mercedes and they are pieces
of art I mean gee wagons there yeah well
yeah they're definitely quite a few of
those and there's one that's that's
camouflage but I haven't seen it yet
done yeah and and and I guess I think
that's the same thing is true with with
our stuff if I if I am owning something
for me because I truly get value from it
then I don't think there's a part of the
ego or at least the bad part of the ego
where I'm worried about that if I'm
trying to impress other people or
impress upon them what I am this kind of
person because I own this widget and we
can remove cars from the whole thing for
a second think about this for a second
the average American throws away eighty
eight pounds of clothes a year and yet
we continue to go shopping for more
clothes and and not just shopping like
oh let me take some cash in my pocket
I'll buy this shirt no let me put that
on the bun
a republic credit card I'll open it up
and save 10% I'd be stupid not to do it
and and it becomes this weird thing
where it's like oh I'm trying to impress
upon you this image as opposed to saying
oh I really like this shirt because it
fits me well or if you I feel good in
this or it's simple or yeah this is how
I get value from it as opposed to man I
really hope this impresses someone else
been reading that book
retired inspired by Chris Hogan yeah he
talks about fake rich and he talks about
how he's like you can live your whole
life like being fake rich and then
really regretting it like when you don't
have any retirement savings or you know
you can live a meaningful life you can
you know cut out the extra expenses and
save for retirement but you know I think
that's another thing too it's like are
you are you know are people buying
things to be fake to look like they're
rich to be fake rich in the short term
which I I know we talked about this on
the podcast before the lake
Ryan it it totally boggles my mind why
do people want other people to think
they're rich like I don't get it it's
because a it's gonna attract the wrong
type of person who I mean if they're
coming at me just because I'm driving a
G Wagon for example well then that's
their product that relation right
exactly to what that relationship you
know guys who buy really nice cars so
they can impress women it's like is Luz
really the type of women you want to
bring into your life a woman that's
gonna judge you just for the type of car
that you drive hmm so yeah it's it's
interesting to me why people even go out
of their way to be fake rich well it
reminds me of we got this tweet on the
minimalist account and this lady said
something about what drives me crazy is
I always feel the need I have to wear
really nice clothes so that so that
minimal like me oh and I'm like a real
man really doesn't give a [ __ ] what
you're wearing I'm if he likes you he
likes you for you and it's not about lay
well I would date her but her heels just
weren't high enough man that sweater was
too orange for me a lot of the pressure
that we feel we think we feel it's not
someone else we're just projecting that
pressure on it's like a self-imposed
pressure that's a good point yeah yes
sometimes all right
question the next question this one is
from sue B is it worth it to rent
something instead of buying it man
that's like another question there's not
just say yes or no answer there is there
right and that's a good good a I mean
it's good news right because some so
think about this one a car you own a car
when we go out on tour we rent cars we
rank we don't go to like oh we're going
to Nashville next month let's buy a car
I'll sell it at the end of tour right
yeah it doesn't make sense in fact I do
one of the things I like about about one
of the things I like about ownership is
it's mine and no one else is like
messing with it it's one of the things
that terrified me about renting things
at first but then I think about when I
rent cars they're like pristine when we
go to enterprise I show up and they give
us like a almost a brand-new Toyota
Camry or whatever and it is pristine
every time I get one because they've
taken care of it I mean you're obviously
paying for that as well when you run it
but it makes more sense for us to rent a
vehicle for a couple of days than it
does to you know buy a car on where
they're obviously or there sometimes
when we go to a city and it's just like
hey let's just take the uber or lyft
option while we're here yeah and that's
essentially what what you're doing with
stuff now is saying hey that you can own
what you want to own what you truly need
but you can kind of rent the rest yeah
and I think it's also about the cost to
you of owning that thing so in San
Francisco if you and a ladder that's
probably taking up a significant amount
of space in your one-bedroom apartment
or your tiny little deck or whatever and
so there's a classic thousand dollar
studio apartment exactly there's a cost
not just the financial cost of buying it
but you have to also think of the cost
to you like psychologically and with a
space in your home of how much does
that's taking up yeah and so we think
about it as you know it's not just a
this ladder cost 50 bucks so I can rent
it for 10 am I gonna use it more than
five times in the next two years it's
about what would that cost be to me to
have that sitting on my porch for the
next two years and how much would I gain
by just being able to have that show up
when I need to but I also think it is
about I mean I'm I'm always hesitant to
like say you know these sort of global
statements about what you should own or
what you shouldn't because maybe you're
super passionate about home improvement
projects and you have your
favorite ladder that you want every time
and you want to own that and I think you
should be able to own absolutely but
it's you know I think it's more about
having that evaluation of what are the
things that I need to own and I want to
own because of these religions and
reasons versus the things that I feel
like I have to own because I might need
a drill to fix a thing at some point
there's a term you guys use for this
about like the what if I just in case
just in case Evans yeah you know how
many of those things do you all have
sitting around the house they you know
with something like Omni or hopefully
many other companies that do this you
could have show up at your door in two
hours when you need to and not have to
own that thing yeah yeah definitely you
know it's funny when I think about the
renting and versus owning I was having a
conversation with my massage therapist
with Meryl I hope she's listening to
this shoutout but we were talking about
ownership versus renting when it comes
to houses yeah and we live in LA and if
let's say owning was you know what I
wanted to do well a I'd have to take out
a 30-year mortgage because there's no
way I could afford to pay cash for a
home in LA yeah the other thing too is
that I would have to hold on to that
house for like five years six years to
to be able to maybe break even versus
renting right versus renting so right
now because you know we are we're not
we're not sold on you know being here
the rest of our lives which we might be
tomorrow we might wake up and be like
yeah we are gonna be here the rest of
our lives right and if that's the case
then I would look at buying something
different but right now for what we're
doing while we're in LA it's better to
rent because again like buying I would
have to hold on to it for five years and
even then like my house I had a condo in
Dayton Ohio and I bought that in 2009 so
it was right after the crash so I got
this really good deal on this condo had
it for six years I lost twenty thousand
I finally was like threw my hands in the
air and I'm like I got to get rid of
this I don't want this mortgage anymore
and I lost twenty thousand now I had to
pay twenty thousand bucks you know
what's fascinating about that yes how
you bought it at the botton though I
bought it at the bottom so a really good
deal was losing twenty thousand dollars
not to mention the you talked about the
other calls the cost of everything you
had to deal with with renting it out to
someone when you move to Montana and
fixing things
then just the burden it was the
psychological burden of it sort of
you're weighing on the back of your mind
yeah that's an additional cost that you
can't quantify monetarily I mean I guess
you can everyone could say well yes you
can pay me $200 a month for the
psychological burden but why well I have
to deal with that yeah I mean the reason
why I'm sharing this too is like anyone
out there who is you know having this
question should I rent should I buy a
lot of like for me I bought because of
that blanket statement it's dumb to rent
it's better to own yeah and I never
really looked past that it was just well
this is what society says so I'm gonna
go ahead and I am gonna buy a house
because I've been running for the last
four years and I might as well buy cuz
this is a better deal I don't think we
often think about why Society says that
with respect to owning a home
we the 30 year mortgage is such a
strange thing I would personally never
take out a 30-year mortgage to to own a
house I can see a case I still think
there's no such thing as good debt you
know and we'll we'll talk about that
next month we're out on them the money
tour that we're on but I can see there's
some debt that is less bad than other
debt and having a you know a 7 or 15
year mortgage you're trying to pay off
really quickly to build up that that
house although I don't I don't tend to
think of you own in your own house as an
investment I think sometimes we we
mistake the the ownership of the home
that we're in is like some sort of grand
investment but as you prove to yourself
even after buying this investment
sometimes we we lose money on it and so
I think that to be really careful about
ownership with respect to well I should
own this because everyone else says I
should own it well that's a ladder or a
drone or a Chewbacca costume yeah you
don't want to hear your Chewbacca
impersonations judge all right our next
question is from Peter Peter says
shouldn't we invest in the things we use
a lot instead of minimizing them buying
a coffee machine is much cheaper than
buying a coffee than buying a coffee
every time we want one now I just buy a
new coffee machine every morning to get
that the freshest cut possible yeah I
wanted to place like plastic a little
bit
I'm gonna buy a new shirt every day yeah
never twice we were in Toronto the guy
who owned the venue there he used to be
in a so we were on tour last year the
guy who owned the venue in Toronto he
used to be in some metal band they would
go out touring and he said the the thing
that was most precious on their Rider
was a new pair of socks and a new shirt
like a pack of new black shirts every
day because apparently when you're a
rock band with six or seven dudes living
out of a van you don't shower a whole
lot and so you just change your
underwear he's not at the top of the
list no you change your underwear you
change your shirt but otherwise no I
mean it and I think the same goes for my
clothes I mean I own the shirt that I'm
wearing here the the same is true I have
a I make coffee at home made coffee at
home this morning and we're not saying
don't own anything we're trying to
figure out we're trying to parse out so
this essay on our website recently the
you saw cuz I saw you tweet about it but
essential non-essential and junk
basically and figuring out what's
essential for you and it's gonna be
different from me versus Ryan versus
Ryan number two and and each of us is
gonna have something different
especially in the second category which
is non-essential things that add value
to our lives most of us have the same
fundamental needs for housing and food
and and your clothing but then beyond
that what adds value to our life they're
non-essentials I don't have to have this
glass I could go to the fountain and
stick my head under it and drink that
way but this adds value to my life so
having this glass is a non-essential but
something that's value the problem is
the third category which is probably 90
plus percent of the stuff that we own
yeah is junk and we pretend it adds
value or here's the other thing there's
almost this weird in-between area where
there are these non essentials that are
actually we don't use most of the time
and I think that's where where you come
in and you say okay maybe you do get
value from it but maybe you only get
value from it once a month or once a
year why why let it take up all that
extra space in the meantime and I think
coffee machines also like to use this
specific example like if you're into
coffee that's a great thing to own like
I love my coffee machine I you know I I
researched them I'm excited about them
and I think I think it's important that
people know that like from art from our
perspective and you guys agree it's like
the things that you love and the things
that you want to own and that you care
about are things that are good and you
know healthy and that's a great thing to
invest in for sure so going with this
same example like I'm thinking about so
I've got a coffee set up but I do pour
over because it's one glass and I don't
waste my neck serve you 60 uh Kaleta
nopalina yeah it's like a colita it's
like the blue bottle yeah the blue
bottle colita I think it's still
considered to colita Hana
I should know this stuff owning a coffee
shop but uh but you know I don't have a
like a coffee maker and when I have I
mean there's one point I had my mom my
grandmother and three siblings staying
with us and all of them drank coffee so
sitting here and got really tired make
it six pour I was like good grief leg I
need to get a coffee machine but I was
like I'm not gonna buy a coffee machine
yeah
just for this every once in a while
thing where I got guests who all drink
coffee and it's a pain in the butt to
make all these pour overs but a thing
like being able to rent one and have one
delivered from Omni and two hours in my
house man that is that's that's a
perfect solution yeah or or now with you
have these apps like a post mates or
something you could get six cups of
coffee delivered probably I don't know I
don't know yeah exactly how that would
work with with coffee but I assume that
you could do that as well and so there's
sort of like these now if you had six
people living with you every day then
that'd be the first story but you would
need a different solution you know for
me I have I have I do two separate pour
overs v6 these and the morning one for
me one for Beck's and I don't wait too
late because I have a coffee with her so
I don't want to make one and then make
the second one and so I just have to set
up and that's what works well for me I
use it every day that is something that
is non-essential but it is pretty damn
close to essential at this point I think
about when I'm thinking about these the
first time I really thought about the
the junk what Ryan and you and I came
with the the 20/20 rule the just in case
rule anything that you don't need you
can replace for less than twenty dollars
in less than 20 minutes or apparently if
Omni is in your city
you can also replace it or temporarily
replace it the when I was going on my
honeymoon so I was 22 years old you
remember you were in my wedding yes with
the strut was it a stretch Escalade
no it was a stretch Hummer oh yeah
that's right it's yeah we were at the
pinnacle we're at peak consumption in my
early early to mid 20s it's so terrible
in any way like I remember going on the
honeymoon and my spouse and I we both
over packed but she over packed
significally she had the biggest
suitcase you know someone got us these
suitcases for for your wedding yeah I
was wedding yes and was like the this
collection of suitcases from extra large
to small basically they like nests like
dolls yes yeah they were but they were
more terrifying because that you could
fill them with stuff right and and so
the the the largest one she had and of
course if you have the largest one you
feel compelled to fill it right with
everything right and so she just jammed
it full of stuff and I had the necklace
oh she had the extra-large I had the
large I filled mine up with stuff as
well and then she had the medium which
she tried to use as a carry-on but they
wouldn't let her because it was too big
and then I had the small which I used as
a carry-on in addition to like bringing
a laptop bag with me this is a one week
honeymoon yeah in Mexico and for some
reason I have a suit with me and I have
like all of these these extra light like
four pairs of swimming trunks because of
course I'm gonna write a different pair
every day right and light of the first
three para get dirty me before polo
shirts and khaki use and what I didn't
even think of what am i doing it's like
what guys in space I have to feel I feel
good on the philip so we get to the
airport so we're flying out with
cincinnati so we drove down to
Cincinnati which is the since I airports
actually in Kentucky and she puts her
bag up on the scale and it's 70 pounds
they're like ma'am you can't do we can't
take this much stuff and so they put my
bag up there and it's 40 pounds well the
limit at the time was 50 pounds
so we had to remove ten pounds from her
bag and put it in my bag we're gonna
remove ten pounds from her other bag and
put it on her carry-on bag which then
she had to check and so we had yeah I'm
doing the math real quick in my head of
damn near 200 pounds worth of stuff 150
pounds of the stuff we another human
with us basically and I can tell you
that like most of that stuff just got in
the way which was like the perfect
metaphor was like I didn't need didn't
end up using much of the stuff and some
of the some of the stuff I used I used
just out of obligation well I brought
four pairs of swimming trunks I might as
well just alternate through them and now
it's like now I'll bring one pair of
workout slash swimming trunks and it
like they they serve multiple functions
and so I think when we think about our
access to stuff we're okay with having
an empty room now you're complete
without filling it it's totally fine and
in fact it's really freeing I remember
we did the the packing party for Ryan
when he like first embraced minimalism
packed up all his stuff as if he were
moving and he went over to his condo
that big condo he was talking about and
it sounded different because you like
you remove the superfluous sort of
things that dampen the sound and all of
a sudden you're like you have this like
echo but it was like a pleasant echo it
was like the echo you get from going to
a Cathedral or something where all of a
sudden you're like oh this is this is
calming I've noticed that I've been
doing this video series on YouTube this
month this past month with doing an turn
a video every day it's called living
room conversations and basically I just
turn on my phone camera and answer one
question a day in my living room and
there's someone's always comments like
there seems to be an echo in there I'm
like no [ __ ] I don't own anything like
that we own exactly what we need and
then also what adds value to our lives
but then we don't have the superfluous
stuff and hopefully there'll be a
service soon where if I do need
something then I can and I can bring it
into my home yeah I was thinking about
this this morning before the podcast how
like when I was in the corporate world I
would buy stuff to fill the space
because I had to space but every time I
bought something it was like this this
affirmation of like yeah man you're
making it you
living the American dream you're able to
do what you want and yet before I knew
it I had a condo full of a bunch of
stuff but man when I finally removed it
it felt so good like being in and that's
for me some people like they like being
around clutter and that's fine but for
me like having an empty room some art on
the wall you know bookshelf a couch like
that's like I'm thinking about my living
room right now I mean it's it's pretty
empty but it is so much better like I
don't look at you know my art and think
man I wish I had ten more paintings or I
wish I had two more couches or uh yeah I
I think that for someone who for someone
who who thinks that that sounds crazy
like try it out meaning like have your
own little packing party maybe in your
living room like think of the room that
you are in the most and and just pack up
as you know whatever you can and see
what it's like to have an empty room I'm
not like a huge believer in function
weight or anything like I really don't
know anything about function why but
like after that packing party I started
to get it I started to understand like
oh okay yeah like when I'm sitting here
on my laptop answering emails from work
like not having a big screen TV in front
of me to distract me it really helps me
to stay more focused it helps me feel
better
I was teaching a writing class this
weekend one of the things I was talking
about was the conversation I had with
Donald right Pollak he's a novelist from
Chillicothe Ohio and he I said well how
do you like cuz he started writing when
he was 55 years old in this really
inspirational story like how how do you
like stay focused and he's like just sit
in the chair like those four words
totally changed my life with respect to
writing because what he was really
saying it was a metaphor for life
remove the distractions no Wi-Fi I don't
have your phone with you no TV or radio
on yeah it's just it's it's removing the
superfluous and then you can bring those
things back in when when you truly need
them as opposed to having them this is
the distractions turned on as if it's a
fireplace going all the time it's just
the glowing screens all around us and
and I get it it's really it's really
intriguing you know I've got a five year
old daughter and she loves watching
Peppa Pig and what's the new one she
watches Pocoyo is the
the new the new kids I guess it's
special the new kids crazy yeah it's on
YouTube and she just loves watching it
but I so I I and the sad thing is like
you know my frontal cortex is fully
developed and I still get trapped by the
glowing screen totally and and so it's
been amazing we just had a six month old
son and how quickly they developed that
that reflex to see a screen and like get
into it was it was incredible and the
weird thing is like you can't like if
you were to if you were to take them
walking them past a house where our
sprinklers going crazy they may not
think a whole lot of it but if they see
that same sprinkler on a television it's
like oh like they're just there's
something about the glowing screen that
yeah it gets them fully enamored into
this this this other world glowing
strings are the pretty addictive man
they are India I was thinking about I
was just in Missoula and we got some
friends each of them have a two-year-old
and watching them use a cell phone and
like how they can hardly talk but they
can but they can use a cell phone pretty
easily it's I don't know it's something
something crazy about the the experiment
were they they dropped off this is I
believe in Ethiopia they dropped off
tablets and the village in Ethiopia
without any instructions whatsoever and
most of the village was was illiterate
and especially little kids they they
they were not literate at all and they
had no instructions no no training and
they just dropped him off in the box and
within a week when they came back the
kids were already they found the way to
get online and they were using the
tablets and showing the younger kids
like the seven year olds are showing the
three year olds how to do it and and I
heard about this on South Dakotans
podcast akimbo and what what I thought
about there is like we we feel compelled
by these screens and they can do really
great things so it's not it's not black
and white it's not by an area we're all
here because of the internet you know
that it's been a great thing for us but
it can also be the greatest distract
I've ever experienced in my life and the
tug of war is trying to eliminate the
distraction while using it for good I
loved what Derek Siver's said when he
chatted with you guys about like he said
the greatest gift I can give my child is
a long attention span yeah and I ever
since I listened that I just been
thinking about that constantly I've just
a how how much of like a superpower
that's gonna be for kids now too you
know if you can develop that twenty
years from now and it's very everyone
has short attention span that's gonna
feel like a superpower for them yeah but
then me how do you I mean everything is
fighting against that culture as you're
raising a kid and how do you start to
consciously think about you know how to
create that in them yeah and I think
what he does is so admirable like world
they'll just go and spend an entire day
at a park and it's testing the limits of
his own attention span as well but I
think what happens when you removes the
distractions you're able to do that and
I've gotten considerably better
especially with Ella and just because
for me I'm just like all right we've
gone to the beach we've seen the sunset
let's go go go right next thing and that
was programmed into me you're probably
as a child but mainly in the corporate
world as well I just get the next thing
done
go tasks tasks tasks tasks all right
sunset is done get in the car buckle up
we're driving to dinner and the next
thing in the you have sit get the ETA
yeah and you have like all of the next
things where as Derek has removed the
the to do's so to speak and and and
instead he sort of has a to B list which
is just the present moment and that's it
yeah and yeah I really I really admire
that and well I don't hope to be perfect
I hope to get closer to that each time
that I I spend time with Ella and I
still catch myself I pull out my phone
or whatever and then I'm like what am i
doing yeah Cal Newport I don't know if
you're familiar with his work he he did
an event with Ryan it was I was supposed
to be there but I was deathly ill and
one of the things that he wrote recently
was about the need for being a digital
grown-up and
the thing that he talked about this is
so good in fact let me see if I can it
might still be a my Instapaper here I'll
pull it up real quick but basically what
what he's talking about is well here
it's right here
digital wellness for grownups we'll put
a link to this in the show notes as well
earlier this week the Washington Post
published an article on the digital
wellness movement which attempts to use
technology to help cure some of the
issues caused by technology by the way
that seems a bit quixotic to me like -
yeah we're if we're just using
technology to - yeah it's like using a I
don't know it's like getting a paper cut
and then taping that piece of paper on
to you to heal the cut in a way this
movement for example is responsible for
an app that quote plants a tree each
time you put down your phone and then
shows the tree with a ring and dying
when you pick the phone back up it also
produced a popular plug-in that displays
each time you go online the number of
days left and your expected lifetime
even Apple is getting involved in
digital wellness their new suite of
quote well-being features in iOS
includes a wake up screen that helps you
quote gently ease into your day when
pick it when you pick up your phone in
the morning and then in an improved Siri
that makes suggestions about optimal
notification settings here's the optimal
notification settings turn them all yeah
that's optimal
I recognize that digital tools have a
useful role to play in product
productivity I've long advised for
example that people use internet
blocking blocking software like freedom
to help jump start deep work training so
Cal Newport book is deep work we'll put
a link to that and the show notes as
well because it's well worth reading but
something about this growing digital
wellness movement makes me uneasy and I
think I finally put my finger on the
source of my concern
it's infantilizing this is so true I'm a
grown man if I if I'm checking my phone
every five minutes or playing video
games set of
paying attention to my kids I don't need
an animation of a dying treat and nudge
me toward better better habits I need
someone I respect to knock the stupid
thing out of my hand and say get your
act together my sense is that more and
more people in our current culture of
digital excess are hungry for this type
of strong a challenge they don't want to
depend on Apple to tweak their OS to be
slightly less intrusive or need to
download an app that provides a fun
reminder about disconnecting they want
instead to be so wrapped up in doing
things that are hard and important and
meaningful that they forget where they
left their phone in the first place
there's something about these new
technologies and the screen zombie
lifestyle that surrounds them that feels
fundamentally childish this is making
people uneasy so that's because they're
ready to grow up and I think that man
the the times where I'm not even tempted
by pacification or distraction are those
times of deep work well I'm doing
something that is deeply satisfying
writing for me is one of those things or
for podcasting we're having these
conversations I don't feel like damn I
need to check my email right now yeah I
wonder if I can you text message stop
and check the news maybe something I
hear what is Trump tweeting about today
yeah it's like okay I mean the times
that I feel compelled to do that is the
times where I feel compelled to I want
to I want to take the path of least
resistance to go with the flow and the
easy route oh yeah I had my doctor's on
the podcast last week and one of the
things I was talking to them about and
this was fascinating like I felt like
the optimal time for my health in my
life or at least what I thought when I
felt really good was age 31 and then
right around 34 35 I started have a ton
of health problems I've worked really
hard the last two years to fix them and
with their help they've helped me out
immensely but I said one thing that I
still feel as sharp as I did when I was
at age 31 like I'm much closer right I
got to a point two years ago when I had
such bad brain fog I thought I was dying
I had a bunch of issues I'd c-diff and
which kills like fourteen thousand
people a year and and and so I had the
set of problems and I had bad brain fog
and I've recovered significantly from
that but I said I won't feel a sharp as
I did when I was 31 but then I also
listened to more podcasts than I've ever
listened to and I'm thinking like oh
wait a minute
like that's just another pacifier for me
like I and so this past week I went and
deleted like 90% of the podcast outlets
so I kept the ones that are like truly
essential for me the ones that I get
immense value from but I've spent the
last week listening to very few podcasts
instead listening to music or just not
bringing my phone with me at all when I
go out for a walk and and using that
time to think and and I have felt a
sense of just a little bit more clarity
like incremental 3% more 5% more of
imagine if that compounds over yeah the
course of a year or something I think
it'll be interesting to see how podcasts
impact time spent reading yeah because
it's a similar I think it's a simple
similar sort of neurological response
I'm like I'm getting this information
this information is valuable but I do
think it's I love podcasts but I do
think there's like a ton of value
psychologically there's a lot of
research to show us that like reading is
important podcast or listening is
fundamentally passive whereas a service
is active yeah and it'll be interesting
you know if I could read Cal Newports
book or if I could go us into two
podcasts at the Cal Newport in ten years
you know which what's gonna be sort of
the path of least resistance I think
it'll be interesting to see you know if
like if reading on a subject becomes
this like very intentional act because
just passively listening to something
while you're doing work and catching the
tidbits is so much easier yeah well I
mean there's this weird sort of payoff
between going wide and going deep to I
mean Ryan and I we've published three
books together and the the best we can
hope for is like a quarter million
copies out there in the world right
which is fun yeah yeah and and but if a
quarter million people don't listen to
this episode I would be devastated right
so it's this weird thing where we're all
of a sudden like you you have this this
this broader base of people but I think
the secret then with the the book it
can't be
laughs exactly it has to go deep it has
to be meaningful and I'm really
encouraged by the new ways that we
publish things now we as a society
because it used to be a book had to be
250 pages right because that way the
publisher could justify charging $40 for
this hardcopy and and now it doesn't
have to be that way I look at you know a
dennis johnson book or a Seth Godin book
these are books are 120 pages sometimes
because it's whatever is necessary and
they cut the excess stuff out of it
right and I think we can do that now and
I think the same is true with with any
other work that we do it's much more
about going deep but it's the reason why
and I and I can say this proudly we've
never had anything that has gone viral
in the sense that I know I I mean there
are a bunch of things I can think of
that have gone viral that quite often
virality is like a car crash though like
people will all turn their head and look
but they're not gonna stick around right
when people find out about the podcast
they tend to stick around or our website
or the documentary will lead them to
other work and then they can go deeper
if they want but if we ever had
something that just went truly went
viral and hundreds of millions of views
somewhere that wouldn't mean anything if
people didn't stick around and it's very
low yeah yeah yeah and and and also the
attention rate is pretty low too right
you get this this burst of attention
there's a study I saw recently the
average American attention span now is 8
to 59 seconds oh wow and so giving your
kid the long attention span just means
greater than a minute I guess at this
point Wow well you know we got to be
careful man because on every single
screen that we that we have that we own
the screens that we see whether it's a
billboard or a digital billboard
whatever that when we're driving down
the road it is we're in a society where
everyone is trying they're vying for our
attention yes like they're going out of
their way to distract us to distract us
to implant a thought in our head that's
gonna make us want to buy what they're
distracting us with yes and I think too
you know Cal Newports point like to be
an adult when it comes to this digital
age we live in
we have to be very deliberate with all
the screens that we have in our homes
and I think especially with kids it's
and it's such a easy thing to give a kid
- you know the kind of babysit them for
a little bit so and you know there's
nothing wrong with TV there's nothing
wrong with a laptop or an iPad or
whatever it may be the problem is is
when we are allowing those those
advertisements those corporations to
distract us - to implant these really
kind of needless needs yeah well there's
a reason that the the rate of depression
and Amish society is nearly non-existent
Wow yeah and part of it has to do with
the lack of distractions and the amount
of deep work that is involved in
everyday life there and true focus and
attention but but it also has to do with
setting up a structure that is
inherently meaningful and I think about
that now you don't have to be Amish to
set up those structures but it becomes
more difficult as you say when when
you're you have these constant
temptations and our and our everyday
life a lot of them it's our own doing
yeah I mean it's a lot of it is is us
yes that looks nice and shiny we want to
get that but not realizing like the the
attention that it's gonna take away from
us
all right man let's move on to our next
question this one's from Bradford I
think access is the key to releasing
yourself from overconsumption
I'd love to hear how to determine what
you need to own versus what you have
access to and then he makes a very good
point here underwear falls into the
ownership camp I assume thank God Ron
are you wearing the other word a day was
it me I'm not wearing any anywhere
well yeah I think so what Bradford is
saying here is yeah it's a good question
I think access is the key to releasing
yourself from overconsumption yeah but
but also maybe but also when I think
about this like I don't think there's a
such thing as too much access but I
think there is
a thing as taking advantage of too much
access yeah you can you can skew the
complete other way so the same way you
get your worth from you know if you're
getting your entire worth self-worth
from the things that you own you're
buying these things for your own ego
what we talked about earlier you could
do that you could go the same thing on
the access route yeah you know you could
you know rent all the cool stuff and you
know do do all that just to feed the
same emotion yeah and so it's not I
don't think access is inherently good
and ownership is inherently bad but I
think it's all about setting yourself up
to be able to live the life that you
want to live well yeah I mean he you
know he said he wants you know you'd
like to hear us to talk about what you
need to own versus what you need to have
access to and that's gonna be different
for every single person yeah everyone's
got different preferences everyone has
different needs me and Mariah we don't
have any kids so we don't need any kids
stuff but you guys you guys need kids
stuff yeah there's like this toy
warehouse down on Miracle Mile and like
mostly inspired by Derek Siver's a
conversation I have with him especially
we did this we filmed the two I will
eventually do something with the footage
we had this backstage conversation with
him now backstage was a weird conference
room we were at a horse track it was the
strangest thing ever but we had this
conversation with him about like owning
toys and and the thing he talked about
on stage is like well you can't be you
know minimalist with kids or whatever
and I think Ryan pushed back a little
bit and said well you know you if you
brought ten boxes of toys for your kid
he's not gonna be any happier with then
with that one box it and so there was an
appropriate mat amount but I realized
that when the babysitter would come over
Chrissy and and babysit Ella she's like
where's her toys and I'm like they're
right there both of them you know like
not not not literally but like I
realized like oh yeah I should probably
get more toys for Ella and not like
force this lifestyle on to her now I did
this video with Ella recently during the
living room conversations we were like
putting together this toy set it was
like Legos don't forget what it was
called but she wouldn't we were building
this hospital so she could inject things
into these little mannequins or whatever
I don't know whatever he said though and
and what I realized like by going and
buying that stuff is like what is the
appropriate amount because the
the study I saw is the average child
owns nearly 300 toys but plays with only
12 daily yeah and that goes back to the
this whole thing of are we just buying a
bunch of sort of distractions and
pacifiers or are these things that the
kids will really get a lot of value from
and if they stop getting value from it
the thing that we do with Ella is we
just have her donate it and she realizes
why they donate it because some other
kid will will be able to play with us
yeah yeah I think when it comes to the
ownership versus access for me like
having having rules like for the things
that I own meaning like the 99 year old
that Josh and I have basically you know
anything that I haven't used in the last
90 days and if I really think about it
not gonna use in the next 90 days I
probably would get rid of it there are a
few things like seasonal items like a
winter jacket or snowboard course that
like it's going to be adjust for when
rather than a just-in-case yeah but I
think like that's the quite or that's
the the thing that people need to do if
they want to really be clear on okay
what do I need to have access to and
what do I need to own what rules do you
have for yourself is it 90 90 maybe for
someone else it's six months six months
or maybe it's a year it doesn't matter
what the number is to help us determine
what we need to own versus what we have
to have access to I think yes we need to
look at our preferences look at our
situation but also just create some
boundaries for ourselves to kind of keep
us from from over yes over consuming I
think Brad's got a really good point the
oh shoot I lost it a lot had another
thought but then I lost it no I I mean
just kind of going off of what Brad was
talking about here yes
you don't have to you don't have to have
access to underwear you should own
underwear and I hope I hope what I hope
is that technology can help us because
if you think about you know 10 years ago
if you needed a car to get to work even
occasionally there was no zip car there
was no get around there was no Oberer
there was no lift Ryan's looking over
here today because access yeah there you
go
taxes were taxis not even impossible to
call where you lived and so you might
actually have needed to own a car and
now it could be totally feasible a
decade later to not own a car
and what I'm hoping we see is that you
know a huge wave of you know basically
technology platforms that allow us to
own you know that sphere that circle
basically grows where now it's sort of
you can get access to cars really easily
but then what if there's that next wave
out of things you could get access to
and then the next wave out after that
because it's all about how easy you can
get access to it if you have to drive
two hours to go rent a stroller for the
nine months you have a kid you're not
going to do that you're gonna just buy a
stroller and Amazon it but if you get
that to deliver to your house and rent
it for nine months you might be way more
likely to do that yeah and so I think
about the very first time we went out on
on tour basically this guy was using
Omni before Omni existed we were in
Albuquerque remember in the guy came out
to us afterward and said hey I need a
chainsaw and they like once or twice a
year and so I will go to my storage
locker and get it and then when I I'll
use it and then I'll put it back on on
the storage locker when I'm done and
that storage locker is called Craigslist
and so he's like I'll buy it for 25
bucks or 30 bucks or a hundred bucks and
I'll sell it back for roughly the same
price as soon as I'm done and I'm like
man one day there's going to be an uber
for chainsaws and and here it is now
there the next question is from Elise
Elise says I use Apple music Netflix
cloud storage and a few other similar
services and I enjoy the ease of
streaming and it's available ability
wherever I go but I feel stressed from
the payments and subscriptions and
emails in my inbox from these services
man the email stressed me out too like I
feel like any time I yeah give out my
email address even if I you know I will
uncheck that box that has automatically
checked every single time that says it's
yeah please send me updates I'll uncheck
it and somehow I still end up getting a
Tony emails but there's a really easy
solution man you just spam them and
eventually like Gmail takes care of it
it just it will filter all that crap out
yeah I mean you you can you can just
unsubscribe is what I recommend yeah I
mean I spend most of my days and email
just unsubscribing from things I never
subscribed to in the first place I can't
tell you how like I don't know if it's
because of like patreon stuff that I do
or if it's people who just have access
to my my email but I
the most random solicited stuff man
like I nothing coming to mind right now
but like just stuff that like you said
never signed up for in the first place
yeah I'm imagining someone has my email
address in the lake oh yeah Ryan will
appreciate it's send me up for it or
something yeah it happens quite a bit so
so I think the first thing is
unsubscribe from the emails you don't
like but if you're feeling stress from
payments I think you have to you have to
work out the math on it right I use
Apple music myself
yeah and it's ten bucks a month I
believe I used to spend way more money
than that on music I mean it was I would
spend easily $100 a month and so I'm
saving $90 a month yeah and so I the the
stress that if I were to feel stress
about defending $10 a month I had to
remind myself that I'm not spending $10
and what i'm saving $90 a month on that
now if you want to go without music
altogether then yeah you can not buy
albums and not subscribe to a service
but in a lot of cases these end up
saving this money i think the same is
true with Netflix I mean Netflix you
know costing less than $20 a month
I mean hell you could you could rent a
few movies from a red box and hey you
have to like take all the time to go out
to the red box I think I assume they
still exist yeah okay
so so basically the time that you spent
plus I mean you're getting an unlimited
version of that now the question
ultimately is are you using it yeah
right because if you're not and you're
just having it because everyone else
says well you got to have Netflix well
then that's a bad a bad reason to have
it yeah there's some services to that
will like I don't know the names of them
but they'll like go through and trim up
like they'll look at all your
subscriptions and they'll tell you what
you're subscribed to and then you can
just in you can one click and they'll
cancel it for you that's pretty awesome
that's by chance
maybe we'll trim maybe yeah maybe maybe
that's trim com maybe we'll look at it
and if we find a look at look it up and
if we find out we'll give it to podcast
Sean to put in the notes it sounds like
an awesome idea I mean yeah I totally
get where where Elise is coming from I
signed up for like the live Hulu TV
stuff Tom
during the Olympics yeah and then you
never cancelled it never cancelled it
and then literally this month I'm like
why the hell my pain is like I never
watched a live TV actually the century I
think I watched a couple basketball
games but but wasn't worth it for me I
could have went to your house and watch
the basketball games ever I really
really wanted to absolutely but yeah if
it's stressing you out at least you've
got to decide what you're willing to pay
for and what you're not willing to pay
for it you know this just goes back to
like minimalism is not easy and it's not
perfect it is simple yeah and simple is
not easy so for Alise they're gonna have
to do some work do some budgeting really
dig into what's important and then
decide what they are gonna keep them
what they're gonna get rid of oh one
other thing I might recommend here is do
a packing party for your streaming
services meaning yeah get rid of them
for a period of time the experiments
that I've done in the past where I got
rid of TV I got rid of a home Internet I
got rid of my cell phone and then they
all three overlapped at one point you go
to your cell phone yeah yeah for two
months and you learn a special kind of
loneliness when you've gotten rid of
home Internet and TV and and the cell
phone you come home and you're like oh
there's just walls here I guess I look
out the window wait look a book let's
see if I still know how to read and it
was although I was talking to the
doctors about this last week it was the
most productive time in my life and then
I realized like I still don't have those
distractions mostly in my life anymore
but I've brought a new distraction in
called podcasts and so now I've
radically limited I went in and deleted
almost all of them and and and that
allows me to say okay if I do miss any
of those that I deleted in the future I
can always bring them back in it's free
to Reese absque Ribe to something yeah
dude I love I love the little stoical
experiments man like I highly recommend
those because like for example your his
cell phone he got rid of for two months
and realized there's like three
payphones and Dayton Ohio they're just
not around anymore
yeah and after two months josh is like
oh man you know what I really that cell
phone adds a lot of value to my life I
got to bring that back in right but it's
you know a it helps you use it
differently helps you look at it
differently but it also helps you
realize like yes this is something that
I do need to have ownership
and so yeah with the streaming services
I think it's a great idea man like Elise
cancel them all and see what you really
really miss and you know if you're
sitting around you're like man I really
wish I had Netflix right now and then go
ahead then sign up for Netflix and just
reactivate enough decks and kind of yeah
just piece it all together yeah love it
all right what's next question next
question is from Miguel this may sound
stupid
oh I sound stupid all the time it's all
right amigo this may sound stupid
but sometimes things take on a
personality like a musical instrument
it's possible to borrow one but there's
just something about playing your own
how do you draw the line between
ownership and temporary access well I
think that I saw a few guitars on on
yeah I was thinking of our friend Colin
right are you familiar with Colin and
also we've been friends for a long time
we started to visit together in 2012 a
publishing company and he travels to new
city or new country every four months or
so and one of the things he likes to
have when he's in the city is a guitars
and he has to go out and buy a guitar
every time he's in a city because he's
gonna rent one for four months or six
months or however long he's there and I
was looking at that I'm like I'll that'd
be perfect if he just needed to like
play it you know once a week or
something you could rent it and return
it or whatever but yeah if you want to
get good at a musical instrument you
probably have to play it every day and
it may make sense to and they make sense
to own one if you just want to give it a
shot for a while though you're not sure
whether or not you're going to to want
one long-term it might make sense to
rent it for a while yeah and then bring
it into your life if you really feel
it's the thing it's the weirdest thing
when you go to buy a car they let you
drive it around a lot for a little while
and maybe get on the highway for three
minutes and then you're like okay I'm
about to make the second largest
financial decision in my life right
based on the last seven minutes one of
the best things that you can do if
you're gonna buy a car is rent that car
from a car rental place and drive it for
three or four days make sure you really
like it and you could do the same thing
with with stuff that you're thinking
about owning yeah I you know it's I
totally see where Miguel is coming from
in fact there are some cultures I think
like Japanese cultures this way we're
like when something turned
a hundred years old like it is it gets a
soul or it takes onto this
this different you know I was gonna say
different form but it's still the same
thing but like you know now it's alive
basically so you know I understand that
sometimes this is this might be a
cultural thing or maybe you know Miguel
it's just you know this is just him and
and in that part of his culture but but
I guess what I'm getting at is is it's
kind of dangerous man so like really
look at stuff like taking on its own
person now usual have a personality and
I'm not and I'm not trying to discourage
Miguel here from really enjoying and
really appreciating the things that he
owns but but looking at something and
starting to treat it like it has a
personality I mean that is a choice that
that one would make am I going to look
at this and continue to you know keep
this thought going that this thing has a
personality or am I going to go out of
my way to just treat this as yes it's
something I really appreciate it but
it's just stuff so yeah Miguel enjoy
your stuff if you got something really
really love awesome man like hold on to
it yeah but be careful man about about
giving your things personalities and
then like you know naming it that that
might be even worse here's a minimal
maxim for you so we usually do these
like we usually answer these with pithy
sort of Maxim's I think this whole time
they doubled the characters on Twitter
yeah you just under the limit you
suppose that want twit longer something
where you just to link in there yeah
it's a link to a rambling basically I
was a Facebook post I was like 65,000
characters Wow but things don't have a
personality but they can't augment your
personality it's good man and and so I
think some things can help you out with
respect to like making you a more robust
person because they will augment the
experience of life but the thing itself
it doesn't have a personality it's an
inanimate object mm-hmm yeah all right
let's move on to one more question here
brian says ownership is made up what do
you guys think about home ownership wait
a minute why does our culture place such
an emphasis
on this so we already touched on this a
little bit it depends I don't look at
home only my own home as an investment I
actually own an investment property back
in Dayton Ohio just a rental home
because I wanted to diversify my
retirement assets and I'm terrified that
the stock market is going to to plummet
any day now and so just because we every
good 9 to 10 year cycles and we have a
reset recession the graph can only go up
into the right for so long yes yeah I
mean that's that's just life yeah you
gotta have the you know in order to have
the peaks you have to have the valleys
and we are we are peaking right now Mark
Twain said history doesn't repeat itself
but it rhymes yeah I love that and so
we're gonna have a rhyme pretty soon and
and so I own a property but it's it's
paid for it's also in Dayton Ohio which
is the third most affordable housing in
the entire country next to Detroit no no
Detroit's more expensive than Dayton
number one is Youngstown number two is
Scranton number three is Dayton Ohio so
so we're in Ohio yeah I mean you could
buy a really nice house in Dayton Ohio
for $30,000 really yeah yeah Wow Belmont
or anywhere on the east side and get a
decent house that's a fixer-upper for
$30,000 so so point being is yeah and
even there there's a bit of a housing
boom compared to where it was a decade
ago but so I'm not against home well the
hoarseness the whole digression there is
am not against home ownership I rent
here in Los Angeles because I couldn't
afford to buy a house in there and I'm
in without getting an extensive well
like a a very long mortgage and and I
don't believe in buying a house
personally for me if I can't put down
bare minimum 20% and do a maximum
15-year fixed-rate mortgage ideally I'd
like to put down half 50% and then have
a seven-year mortgage that hopefully I
even pay off closer before before the
seven years is on
that's how I feel about home ownership
personally yeah it's it's our personal
preference when I try to make anyone
feel bad about having a 30-year mortgage
yes but I know for me like thinking
about signing up for a 30-year mortgage
it's the reason why I would not do that
is I don't know where I'm gonna be 30
years from now and yeah functionality is
important yeah it's it's you know um is
it Sybaris who talks about renting is
the it's the it's buying the the free
the freedom yeah to move yeah right and
let that's what I have right now I have
the freedom to move like if if you know
the rug was swept out from underneath of
me I could just put my hands in the air
and leave my apartment and go move back
to Dayton Ohio and be a barista and be
fine because I did not put myself in
that that pressure of having to pay that
mortgage I mean for me um yeah a 30-year
mortgage it's just too long of a
commitment because dude I mean honestly
I know where my direction is in the next
five years I know where I want to be but
I really don't actually know where I'm
gonna be yet so yeah that's that's our
personal preference um yeah the other
thing is you the break-even on a
mortgage like that the reason I say the
other the other factor that I would
throw in there is if you're not going to
live in a city for at least five years
more ideally seven then then you
probably don't want to buy me out I
think of people who are say in the
airforce they're moving every three
years it probably doesn't make sense for
someone like that to buy a new house
every three years you're just gonna
you're gonna lose a lot of money and
even really yeah pretty lucky to break
you yeah you're gonna lose a lot of
money on closing if you'll have enough
money put down you what you're gonna pay
a lot on PMI and so there's a lot of
reasons not to buy home there are a lot
of good reasons to buy one as well I
mean let's let's say you know you're
gonna be somewhere for the next thirty
years this is the the house you want to
settle down and you feel really good
about that you've got enough money to
put down and then yeah you don't have to
rent in perpetuity
um thankfully there is not a black and
white I own a house and I rent an
apartment oh my god yeah minimal is such
a hypocrite no man I mean I just see
your point Josh I I think just to echo
there isn't a wrong there isn't a right
way to do it the only time it's wrong is
when you are making a decision that's
wrong for you and your family
are you are you doing something that is
going to put needless pressure on
yourself that's gonna make you work 60
70 80 hours a week you might want to
look at it and say you know what maybe I
don't want to put myself in that
situation but ultimately yeah you're
right Josh there is not there's not one
way to do it right yes indeed well let's
see well we do have one more for this
one's from Brad Brad said what happens
when access goes away say I need to get
say I get rid of all my DVDs in favor of
using streaming services but who knows
they can go out of business someday so
if you'd like to hear our answer to that
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast head on over
to the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes all of our monthly ask the
minimalists anything episodes unreleased
recordings of our live events and the
entire back catalog of past private
episodes and once you become a supporter
over at the minimalists comm you'll
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so that it plays in
whatever podcast app you are using and
as a patreon supporter you also receive
access to our monthly live stream videos
as well as first access to tickets to
all of our live events before those
tickets are available to the general
public you find all the good stuff over
at the minimalists comm slash support
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently
Ryan man well since Ryan's here I got a
recommend Omni so you can find out more
about Omni at be Omnicom you can check
them out on twitter at on knee or at
delq I'm assuming that's your personal
yeah yeah I know it's a yeah it's you
know I love how you're expanding and
hopefully dude like you can keep
expanding you guys can keep expandable
next couple years man and anything we
can do to help let us know make you
would love to help so Ryan if people
aren't in the cities you're in so
they're not in the Bay Area they're not
in Portland yet but they're interested
in learning more they can obviously go
to the website is there anything else
they can do to to compel you to come to
their City yeah so if you sign up we're
if you have a wait list going for every
city okay so if you sign up with your
zip code that's gonna influence where we
come
man what a great idea you like yeah you
liked in the the the yeah where the need
is where the needs the the greatest man
that's that's a genius idea and as soon
as the sound of you're just gonna spam
them every day with a bunch of odd right
they will not get any emails until we
till we are coming to this okay that's
good beautiful beautiful well I had a
recommendation there's this album that
came out by Robbie hight and Caroline
Spencer it's called two people and it is
like the perfect sort of love song album
and like it made me all sad because I
was dropping backs off at the airport I
was gonna see her two weeks and late it
was like the the soundscape to this this
like departing but then there's this
this song and Sean maybe we can play
this at the end of this episode
unless you're listening to this on
YouTube then we'll put a link to it in
the show notes but if you listen to the
audio there's a song called I'll keep
you and it was the perfect expression of
like it's almost a song about like
garage sales in a way where it's like
finding these things that trigger
memories in the attic and like it made
me think of this good time but really
the thing I want to keep is this
experience this relationship and this
stuff is stuff and it can be nice it can
it could be good for our lives but it's
not this it's not the interaction it's
not the experience I'm living it's just
stuff so it's called I'll keep you and
we'll we'll play that at the end of this
episode awesome and I have to check it
out before we do that let's move on the
right here right now so we're talking
about what's going on the lives of the
minimalist so my 37th birthday was on
Friday and we're trying to help build a
grocery store in Dayton Ohio so that
people have access to good food but also
access to information because there's
food on the west side of Dayton but it's
like food and quotes you know you can go
to the corner liquor store and buy
Cheetos right you can buy calories
basically but they're empty calories is
not a whole lot of nutrition and so we
want to give people access but also
education so Ryan and I have had a few
meetings with the folks from Jim City
Market and we've decided to help them
out we try to work on one or two big
philanthropic projects a year went over
the past few years have been able to do
a bunch of stuff we built an elementary
school we funded a high school for a
year we helped out the victims of the
oral
no mass shooting and and the Las Vegas
mass shooting and a bunch of other stuff
we try to find ways to help and this is
the way we're gonna help so Ryan and I
are gonna donate a large chunk of our
own personal money to this and and then
we need your help for the rest we're
trying to raise a hundred thousand
dollars here so if you go to the
minimalists comm slash Dayton you can
learn about the grocery store exactly
where it's going to be and if you donate
thirty seven dollars that's how old I am
right now so that's what we're asking
for if you can't afford 37 you wanna
donate five bucks or whatever then
please do whatever you can afford if you
can afford ninety dollars you're gonna
buy a lifetime membership for an entire
family and Dayton so you can definitely
help out there also Ryan and I are going
on tour we're going on three cities
where it's called the simply southern
tour we're gonna talk about money and
minimalism we're gonna be in Nashville
and Birmingham Alabama and Kentucky will
be in Louisville and so we're gonna
special guests with us we'll have Rachel
Cruz and Anthony O'Neill and Chris Hogan
you talked about Chris Hogan's book
earlier I don't think I've ever been so
excited for a tour man it's like it's
gonna be different from anything we've
ever done definitely and we have just
I'm a little nervous because like the
people the guest so we have like they're
really gonna make me look dumb but you
know it's not about me it's about it's
about the listeners so the listeners are
really gonna enjoy the nice thing is
we're going to get an education on stage
while we're they absolute
the nice thing about it's a bit of an
immersive experience that you can read
their books and there's a lot of helpful
information in there in fact I did a
YouTube video about the the five or six
different books but help people get out
of debt during the this living room
conversation series I've been doing and
I did five or six books on helping
people get out of debt and three of the
books were from three of the people
here's a Rachel and Anthony I'm Chris
and so they're gonna be on stage with us
we'll be answering your questions about
money and minimalism and everything in
between that's July 20th 22nd and 24th
all the details are over at our website
the minimalists comm slash tour also
real quick Ryan our book minimalism is
now available in Spanish it's in outta
here yeah it's when did that happen last
week chillin Simon and
in Colombia and Mexico and Uruguay and
likely some other countries as well so
the only thing isn't a Portuguese yet no
it is not this the only because we get
the biggest
yeah the two biggest asks or Portuguese
in Spanish not in that order but that is
awesome and we're like yeah halfway
there yes we're in over a dozen
languages now if you are in any of those
countries you can go to your bookstore
and you should be able to find it there
oh and if you want access to all the
show notes you always hear me talk about
hey Sean podcast show I'll put that in
the show notes then just put your email
address in over at the minimalists comm
at the top you'll get any of the show
notes any new podcast episodes we put
out there but you know what you won't
get what spam nobody likes spam yeah
well and we also won't sell your email
to anyone I just get the why you get
like yeah it must have got some email
yeah busy guy oh five nine Ryan's first
email address his grandma will run set
up for me why did she say a busy guy I
don't know we were just sitting that we
were trying a million different things
and they're like all taken yeah like
yeah like at the time like I think I was
working I was just like working a lot or
something she's like let's just try a
busy guy that didn't work and it
suggests that you know how to suggest
something I have and that's what I yeah
no I don't have that well I don't have
that I have a yahoo that is like my spam
why am i giving my spam email I do have
a busy guy email address but it's yeah
it's not that means there was a busy guy
at one through four it's already taken
yeah and busy busy guy at AOL I don't
dude I mean it is it is some of the
email addresses that that we came up
with is just hilarious and general like
we never really thought that email would
be something we use professionally like
printed somewhere right exactly and then
yeah like and I still everyone so I will
come across you know like cheetah print
girl at hotmail calm
by the way I apologize to busy guy at
aol.com and also cheetah print girl for
all this spam we're sending you our bed
yeah please don't send email to those
addresses that's probably someone
through email yeah anyway Ryan you got
anything else for us no man all I got
here some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners Joe from Dallas I was
listening to some old podcasts your
collection one I'm a disc golfer and I
used to have 500 plus discs of which I
had probably thrown 50 of them more than
one time I had a big bag of putters 20
putters I used to carry around the
practice cutting room one day I bought a
smaller bag so I could walk around with
the putters and not have quite as much
weight only fit six putters in it
I had forgotten my larger bag and just
had the smaller bag when I went out to
play the next time and I had to grab
five discs to take on my round and I
shaved four strokes off of my best round
ever it was not a fluke I continued to
play with a smaller bag with only five a
couple of drivers a couple of midranges
couple of putters and I kept getting
between two and five less than I had
ever played before I could only throw
what I was really comfortable with
because that's the only choice I had and
I became a much more skilled disc golfer
by cutting down those options
hi this is Emily from Oklahoma City my
tip is for Jason from the reset episode
he was asking his minimalism is linked
to health or they think if he thinks it
encourages health and I'm my intake on
his question was that being a minimalist
and taking away the pacifiers per say in
your life allows you to feel and see
your issues with more clarity and more
authenticity and so taking all of those
away and accepting where you are allows
you to move forward whenever someone
doesn't have a pacifier and they're
authentically feeling issues or ones
that they're having in their lives it's
a lot easy easier to identify and move
forward
hi my name is Ashley from Chicago and I
just wanted to call in and leave a
general tip for those people who are
trying to improve their writing it's an
app that I've been using called
grammarly it's basically a free app that
will scan the text that you have written
for any common grammar mistakes there is
a subscription if you really wanted to
kind of do a boost that will kind of
give you hints of you know other words
that you could be using or if there's
like a ma non sentence it will help
break it down for you but I've noticed
that ever since I started using this app
and I've been using the free version
that my writing has become more
intentional and I've also been a little
more aware of what I'm writing
and generally it's helping me improve my
writing skills so instead of just typing
on the email and sending them on over
I'm actually typing out checking my my
message through grammar early and has
definitely been helping and improving my
skills alright y'all that's it for this
episode if you have a question or a tip
a comment for our listeners or for the
minimalist podcast give us a call for 0
6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 love to hear what you
have to say about access versus
ownership where our favorite comments
and tips on the next episode you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm if you'd rather do
that than call and if you leave here
with just one message before that Ryan's
Alcona thank you for being here man yeah
thanks for having me make someone a real
pleasure this is great and I'm grateful
for what you're doing because we often
talk about access is greater than
ownership in many contexts and now we
actually have a market solution for that
and if there's anything we can do to
help add value to get that message out
there where [ __ ] we're more than willing
to help out thanks for having me thank
you for being here and if you all leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this I love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
minimus